también necesitamos invertir en investigación y desarrollo.
¿Cómo sería esto?
En 1966, EE. UU. invirtió un 0,5 % de su PIB en el programa Apolo.
Llevó personas a la luna ida y vuelta, de manera segura.
Hoy en día, 0,5 % del PIB son unos USD 100 mil millones.
Sabiendo que la captura directa de aire
es uno de los frentes de nuestra lucha contra el cambio climático,
imaginen si pudiéramos invertir el 20 %, es decir, USD 20 mil millones.
Es más, imaginemos si podemos reducir los costos
a USD 100 la tonelada.
Será difícil, pero es lo que hace que mi trabajo sea interesante.
¿Cómo sería USD 20 mil millones a USD 100 la tonelada?
Para ello, hay que construir 200 bosques sintéticos,
cada uno con capacidad de capturar un millón de toneladas de CO2 por año.
Eso representa cerca del 5 % de las emisiones anuales en EE. UU.
No parece mucho,
pero es, en realidad, muy significativo.
Las emisiones generadas por el transporte de larga distancia
y las aerolíneas comerciales,
suman alrededor del 5 %.
Nuestra dependencia de los combustibles líquidos
hace que estas emisiones sean muy difíciles de evitar.
Así que esta inversión podría ser completamente significativa.
¿Qué superficie terrestre se necesitaría para hacer esto?
Doscientas plantas,
que ocuparían cerca de la mitad de la superficie de Vancouver.
Esto, si funcionaran a gas natural.
Pero recuerden que la desventaja del gas natural es que también emite CO2.
Y si usamos gas natural para capturar CO2 directamente del aire,
acabaremos captando alrededor de un tercio de lo que se pretende,
a menos que se use el sistema inteligente de la cocaptura
aplicado por "Carbon Engineering".
Si tuviéramos un sistema alternativo y utilizáramos energía eólica o solar,
la superficie debería ser 15 veces mayor, como el tamaño de Nueva Jersey.
Una de los temas que me ocupan en mi trabajo y en mi investigación
es optimizar estas plantas y evaluar dónde instalarlas
y pensar en los recursos locales disponibles,
ya sea tierra, agua, electricidad asequible y no contaminante.
Se puede usar, por ejemplo, electricidad no contaminante
para separar el agua y producir hidrógeno,
que es un sustituto excelente del gas natural -- libre de carbono, además --
para suministrar el calor necesario.
Pero quiero que reflexionemos de nuevo sobre las emisiones negativas.
Las emisiones negativas no deben considerarse un remedio milagroso,
pero pueden ayudarnos si seguimos atascados
a la hora de reducir la polución de CO2 a nivel mundial.
Por eso tenemos que tener cuidado.
Este método es tan atractivo que hasta puede ser riesgoso,
pues algunos pueden aferrarse a él
como si fuera la solución definitiva a la crisis climática.
Puede tentar a la gente a quemar combustibles fósiles 24 horas al día,
365 días al año.
No deberíamos considerar las emisiones negativas
como un sustituto para detener la polución,
sino como un elemento más de un portafolio que ya existe
y que incluye todo,
desde una mayor eficiencia energética,
al carbono de bajo consumo,
a la agricultura mejorada.
Algún día, todo esto nos llevará al camino de las emisiones negativas.
Un poco de autorreflexión.
Mi marido es médico de urgencias.
Y me maravilla el trabajo que él hace con sus colegas
para salvar vidas todos los días.
Y cuando hablo con ellos de mi trabajo para capturar carbono,
veo que ellos también se maravillan.
Y eso es porque combatir el cambio climático capturando el carbono,
no se trata solo de salvar un oso polar o un glaciar.
Se trata de salvar vidas humanas.
Puede que un bosque sintético nunca llegue a ser tan bello como uno de verdad,
pero podría permitirnos preservar no solo el Amazonas
sino a todas las personas que queremos y valoramos,
además de las generaciones futuras
y la civilización moderna.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)